you know what's so [ __ ] funny too i
had no idea it was that easy
to storm a government office well that's
that's right that's the most shameful
thing about it
i'm like i thought all of our money went
into our military and our armed officers
what the [ __ ] i didn't know it was that
easy if it was that easy i would have
broken to the white house
and [ __ ] slap trump around his fat
juicy ass i would have
i would have got that duck booty and i
would have cussed that [ __ ] super hard
baby but that's the thing
is that even though there was
kind of like that in five four three two
one what's up everybody welcome to
another episode of the genius brain
podcast
if you are a first time listener you are
in for a [ __ ] doozy
this is the best podcast in the world
every other podcast you listen to is
trash
it sucks even my friends podcast yeah
the only
only one that's uh i guess might get a
little pass
would be tiger belly then right oh yeah
shout out to the father of all podcasts
the man who actually got me into a
podcast
again aside from that yes everything
else is garbage
bobby lee i love you very much you are
the best uh
you're the only person i know that has
shat in his car more than six times in
his whole life oh my god
really this dude has [ __ ] in his car
so many [ __ ] times like he can't hold
his bowels wow so he just
pooped does he does he have ibs or some
[ __ ] or maybe
and a lot of other problems too i love
that man dude he's the best
this whole like on his podcast has
openly admitted to sucking dudes dicks
you know this no so well it's i guess he
kind of got molested
not by an older man though by like one
of his friends oh no
so he told this he told this story on
his podcast where
uh he had like either a best friend or a
really good friend from back at home
yeah
and i guess you know when you're a kid
you don't really know you're kind of
experimenting you don't know what's
really cool
how old like what what's like elementary
school okay
like super young but i guess like they
would i don't know they would pay like
suck a dick or some [ __ ] like like a
game
oh my god and after a while i think he
was just kind of like
i don't think this is right you know but
he jokes about it but it's very serious
yeah i only laugh about it because he
laughs about it well you know i mean
obviously that's a [ __ ] up scenario
but what's even more
[ __ ] up is this sociopath of a friend
that he has
at that age where he's already plotting
and he's that devious
but he goes through therapy and stuff to
work his stuff out but i think a lot of
comics have these weird back stories
dude humor comes from dark places oh for
sure this is extreme though that's why i
told them
that's pretty extreme that's that's god
awful dude i put this down
right now yeah bobby lee is the most
gangster person i know on earth because
he's the only guy i know
that has sucked dick from a guy on
purpose
but never went to prison once and it's
still straightforward
dude that's crazy bro i have no idea
dude
if you just listen to tiger belly it's
some of the most insane stuff i've ever
heard in my life like you would think
so i guess recently too he had carlos
menci on his podcast and i was listening
to this morning yeah
but they were recounting the story about
how when uh
him and carlos mencia went to honduras
and you know it sounds so ridiculous
when he tells the story but carlos messi
is like no he's telling the truth this
is exactly what honduras is like
it's it's [ __ ] nuts because you know
when bobby it seems like he's being
extremely
like hyperbolic yeah but you know carlos
mastio's like no this is some real [ __ ]
wait so um i thought there was kind of
like that whole beef with like mencia
and like joe rogan and like oh joe rogan
hates his guts
yeah but when it came to carlos mencia's
stuff bobby
has always said on the podcast that he
was a mentor to him
so when bobby was like a nobody comic
carlos mencia was actually the guy that
was showing him the ropes put him on the
road with him
and he was very very generous so bobby
has only said great things about him
joe rogan on the other hand yeah [ __ ]
hates his guts right i mean
but he has a legit gripe right and i'm
the dude was [ __ ] swagger jacket
i wonder why but the only thing that's
odd to me about the whole joe rogan
thing
is that carlos mencia is not the first
person to ever do that yeah so
why specifically carlos mencia also
because joe rogan has defended amy
schumer
and amy schumer has stolen way more
jokes
and has reached the bigger fame probably
than carlos mincy ever has
exactly yeah so but on like somebody was
i didn't see this episode but people
were telling me that joe rogan was like
no like he was defending amy schumer
i'm like that means that there's
something deeper behind the carlos
mancia thing that people
aren't that he's not saying and carlos
won't talk about yeah yeah probably
i bet you they were friends or homies or
some [ __ ] and i don't know carlos smith
probably just
nutted on earth or or in joe rogan's
mind he just he was just
always that dude where it's just like i
want to kick his ass yeah he don't like
he just didn't like him
i just don't like this dude you know
that's all the reason he needs yeah
but i don't know what the whole
reasoning behind that [ __ ] is though but
hey
um there was a there was a photo back
here i just wanna
just in case the homies see that if you
guys have not noticed
so this so my buddy tommy a dope artist
a
friend of mine he's actually been on
this podcast before he makes some of the
dopest [ __ ] i've ever seen in my life
and specifically
he had this tyson dmt uh art art piece
that he did
now this one right here there's somebody
i know his name is nose rain also
a great uh artist as well hey
i love you dude it just wasn't matching
i didn't take your photo out
because i don't like your art yeah it's
just it was the odd man out
yeah exactly you were [ __ ] up the
power ranger zordon
the zord the voltron man yeah you were
[ __ ] up the the
you know voltron vibe so i had to get
rid of it uh
but that's that's just what that is but
check out tommy's stuff you could check
out uh nose rain stuff too it's really
amazing but
i had to kick your [ __ ] out because it
was [ __ ] up the vibe but
um today though we're gonna hum and
there's so much [ __ ] that happened
there's
a lot of [ __ ] man so last week we kind
of lightly touched on this topic
where uh people were asking yo
you should talk about the the attack on
the capitol in dc
right so when i was shooting the podcast
with alex and
pat yeah it literally just happened that
day and i wasn't online like i wasn't
really looking into anything
so i was finding out information about
it as they were talking on the podcast
yeah
right with the dude that was dressed as
the [ __ ] trailer park braveheart
you know the [ __ ] guy with the
buffalo hat yeah when they were telling
me that [ __ ] i thought they were joking
yeah yeah but
literally this dude had a cut off
buffalo head on his head yeah that
is a [ __ ] psychopath i you know
i saw it happening life as it was
breaking out and i was like you know
what
it's a sad day in american history but
i'm not surprised
you know i am not surprised especially
with the guy
who's the guy at the helm who's the guy
who's instigating all this
who's the guy who's you know inciting
this yeah so when i was kind of
you know looking into it right and the
reason why i don't want to talk about it
so quick off the bat is because i
literally didn't know anything about
what was going on it just looked like
chaos and mayhem
and so the first thing i looked up was
how the [ __ ] did this
happen what the [ __ ] happened on capitol
hill
right and so then i was reading a couple
of quotes and
you know when people say because when i
read certain headlines i'm very
uh skeptical about what i'm reading just
because whether you're on the left or
the right
uh media will always sensationalize
whatever they're saying
or what's what's actually happening so
you know the what people were saying was
that it was because of what trump said
during a very specific speech and i'm
like
that [ __ ] well we'll see about that
i can't find the quote right now but
this will literally said storm the
capitol
yeah he said dude he said in his words
like we can't be weak we can't be weak
right now
you know uh we need a fight i mean you
even had
guys like rudy giuliani saying trial by
combat
what the [ __ ] you mean trial by con what
the [ __ ] are you talking about bro
in the [ __ ] 16th century you [ __ ] are
you talking about man
that's [ __ ] nuts to me dude yeah so
you know uh all that [ __ ] kind of uh
led up to today which was the first
president in history to be impeached
twice
uh [ __ ] crazy yeah and and uh for
incitement of insurrection and that's
exactly what it was it was an
insurrection
right so it was a wild thing to watch
unfold
um and like i you know there's a lot of
things to get into it within that but
i think kind of the uh one of the things
that really bothered me a lot about the
whole thing was like
everyone was obviously pointing out at
how terrible the situation was
but then you had the the staunch trump
reporters
who were was they were playing the whole
what aboutisms again
well what about black lives matter
movement and and that riot
it's like come on man it's that's a
[ __ ] completely separate thing
because the black lives matter movement
the protest the peaceful protest
largely were peaceful were organized
was orderly and then you had these uh
rogue agents coming in it was in the
writing parts and the looting part
that was not organized yeah that was
just scattered and happening
all throughout different areas this
was a different situation they were on a
mission
they went there for a purpose and they
were galvanized by the president of
the united states by something he
specifically said he's like we should
storm the capital
yeah i might be butchering the actual
code i can't find it but i read it
earlier today and i was watching the
video where he said it
and i was uh even for for trump i was a
little shocked
yeah and this is what i'm talking about
when when i've said this before
when it comes to who he is and what
he does we could talk about you know
people love to talk about economics
right they're like well you don't know
what trump has done for this country
economically speaking and i'm like [ __ ]
neither do you you [ __ ] don't no
you don't have numbers you just say
broad things just like i do a lot of the
times too and that's where i [ __ ] up a
lot right
but besides all that i can't be behind
somebody
whether or not you could talk about you
know he's from you know money you know
he knows business and all this other
stuff
we could talk about all that stuff at
another time but what
is important to me when i look at
somebody who wants to leave this country
is somebody who understands
how [ __ ] powerful his words are yeah
and he doesn't get it
people keep saying he's a genius i don't
think he's a genius
i i really do believe he says things
yeah off the cuff the cuff yeah with his
emotions yeah and he doesn't think about
the actual consequences
such as this [ __ ] i mean come on man he
set the pence
do you want to go down in history as a
patriot or do you want to go down in
history as a [ __ ]
you can't make this [ __ ] up bro that's a
fire ass line you can't make that [ __ ]
up
like this guy is [ __ ] something else
and and
the craziest [ __ ] about all of this what
what what it's stemming from is
the idea that there was widespread fraud
in the election
and in the voting process there still
hasn't been a single piece of credible
evidence that has come
out to substantiate those claims of
course not but
people still run with it and they they
will not
listen to objectiveness they won't
listen to the facts
yeah they won't listen to reason and
that's the part that's the scariest
thing man because it's like
this might be kind of um
an introduction of what's to come this
this might be
like the prologue you know what i mean
because next week now we have the
inauguration
and there's already talks about the
bugola boys
kind of organizing oh really yeah
already huh
and you know those guys are like a
militarized like gorilla group
you know what i mean and so you got the
national guard
sleeping in the hallways of capitol hill
like they were saying news anchors were
saying
even after uh 9 11 it wasn't even like
that
you know what i mean like it there was
not that amount
of uh presence security presence on on
capitol hill even after 9 11.
you know what's so [ __ ] funny too i
had no idea it was that easy
to storm a government office well that's
that's like that's the most shameful
thing about it i'm like
i thought all of our money went into our
military and our armed officers
what the [ __ ] i didn't know it was that
easy if it was that easy i would have
broke into the white house
and [ __ ] slap trump running his fat
juicy ass i would have
i would have got that duck booty and i
would have cussed that [ __ ] super hard
baby but that's the thing is that
even though there was kind of like that
whole idea of storming the capital
how under-prepared they were for that
and how how much they didn't organize
for that
can you imagine if it was a group of
minorities
yeah who who were saying that we're
gonna storm the capital you think they
would it would have been the same kind
of response
no the national guard was sent in for
the blm movement
where the [ __ ] was the national guard
for this yeah right
i mean of course the trump's not going
to call them in that's his people
yeah you know he had no choice but to
say what he said afterwards of like oh
you guys need to go home and not do this
type of [ __ ] dude though i found out
later on too obviously because i'm
you know the reason why i'm kind of late
with all this information is because
sometimes i just it's hard for me to
read this stuff yeah because
last year when we were going through
this stuff i just sat in my room and i
kept reading things over and over and
over
and it was [ __ ] exhausting man it was
[ __ ] up my psyche yeah it was it was
making me angry
yeah it was making me upset yeah and
there was an officer that was actually
killed there too
yeah so we're having this conversation
right now where
i've heard so many times over and over
and over that blm
is anti-police force right and it's all
about blue lives matter exactly you guys
literally mod the capital
and you murdered a police officer with
the [ __ ] the fire extinguisher
irony is just perfect man right it's
just perfect and then even though this
stuff is addressed
there's a lot of what about isms that
come in and mind you too this is also
this also happened with the blm movement
when it was come to writing right
because
i had a big issue with that as well i
had an issue because i'm pro blm
and there was comments that were saying
like well we're not being heard so we're
just gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] up i don't agree
with that no i'm not a part of that for
sure
exactly you know exactly that's what a
reasonable person says yeah
that's what a reasonable person says you
can look at something that you support
and if you find something wrong in it
point that out right
i said the same [ __ ] i'm with it i'm
with the protesting
i'm with the movement but the violence
the looting
no there's no place for that [ __ ] so why
can't
the same thing be applied here in this
situation if you're a
staunch trump reporter i mean that
reporter um
supporter and you're looking at this
[ __ ] happen why can't you say
yeah what happened was wrong that should
not have happened
that was an attack on democracy like the
core foundation of this country
this podcast is brought to you by june b
matcha do you hate the jitters and crash
that coffee gives you well
say no more my friends because hundreds
of thousands of people are drinking
junebe matcha not only for the health
benefits but for the caffeine boost that
lasts without the crash of coffee you
can mix it
have it hot ice cold or try it with your
favorite juices and have
fun with it remember not all matcha is
created the same and junebe has the
highest quality matcha you can find
straight from a farm in japan
hand-picked and curated to get you the
best quality there is
no competition to get 10 off your first
order of tins and packets go to
junebeshop.com that's j that's j-u-n-b-i
shop.com and enter code geniusbrain to
get 10
off your first order that's
j-u-n-b-i-shop.com
code geniusbrain instead it's like
well no but look at what happened during
the black lives movement yeah why can't
we find common ground
in in blatant stupidity that's that's
the crazy thing to me when
when you see people who are a part of
this nation right they go
in they storm the capital looking like
trash bag hillbillies
right the dude dressed in the [ __ ]
buffalo hat
here's the another alarming thing that
people don't really think about right
we've already discussed multiple times
how when it comes to these type of
organized
groups there's people who infiltrate it
right we talked about antifa all this
other stuff
you guys stormed the [ __ ] capital
with people who knew that this was going
to happen
what makes you think for one [ __ ]
second there weren't people in that
group
that's there that that's there to hurt
this country this is not something that
i'm like mr
i'm not a conspiracy theorist at all
right right but there was computers
stolen with
[ __ ] physical data and information in
there yeah that
is [ __ ] nuts you know they found
bombs too
they found and the fbi is not sure why
it didn't go off but it was
legit bombs with timers on it so it's
like
that's [ __ ] nuts what what are we
trying to do here yeah what what are we
really trying to accomplish here
are are we trying to start a revolution
or not we
are these people trying to start a
revolution is is that the goal here like
what i didn't understand what what is
the goal what are you trying to do here
what is the purpose what's the end game
yeah what is the end game what
was gonna happen do you think doing this
is gonna overturn the election
nothing is gonna change like you have to
understand that
so with that in mind with that in mind
what the [ __ ]
is the goal what are you trying to prove
are you trying to prove
based on your [ __ ] facts and your
conspiracy theories
that there was widespread election fraud
i mean the amount of [ __ ]
organization
and colluding that needs to take place
for that to happen on a national level
america's not capable of it it's insane
and you know what's funny too like i
i kept seeing these small clips yeah
where there were people that were
quote-unquote whistle-blowing saying
like yo these people are not counting
ballots or whatever
but then i did even which for me when i
seen that i was like oh that's kind of
[ __ ] up
it's like [ __ ] up see it it makes your
gas control
but you know there's a lot of people who
are a part of the republican party
saying like listen i wanted trump to win
right but the idea that you think
that our system like our voting system
in america is that bad
like yeah there's there's uh voter fraud
that happens at a very small scale
every time somebody becomes the
president those people who have those
ballots
every four years they're gonna dump a
few off here and there because there's
some sick [ __ ] who will do that
that's been happening since ever but the
amount that they're saying that he needs
with 11 12
is not around right either way he would
have lost it doesn't [ __ ] matter
so people won't even they won't even
listen to that like these are just facts
this is not something that people are
just saying to you know bolster their
side
it's just these are facts these are
people on your political side that are
saying this
so there's some type of reasoning for
this take the l
move on leave with grace have the people
who loved you love you and then that's
it
that's all it takes exactly man he
doesn't care about this country because
you can see it in how he's behaving even
when he addressed telling people to go
home
the first thing that he said before
telling people hey this isn't the right
thing to do he goes
oh i'm so mad there's voter fraud i know
i'm right there with you he still has to
bring it back towards him
this guy's a level fifty thousand
narcissist
who he is for sure the ego and the
narcissism is out of control and
the saddest part about that [ __ ] is is
the group of people that he's duping
yeah it's blue-collar workers and people
thinking that
they he actually gave a [ __ ] about him
you know
he doesn't he does not give a [ __ ] about
any of these people
he only cares about himself you guys are
just giving him a platform
to be able to you know kind of embrace
himself in that way
yeah and it's it's [ __ ] ridiculous
and you would read tweets
from you know people from the far right
wing side
saying this was a protest you know when
peop
and there was the what about isms where
they said when they were
uh marauding and looting target and
walmart
those are riots this isn't a riot you
don't see people stealing [ __ ] and then
it's literally photos of people stealing
podiums
competitors that got listed listed on
ebay bro they got listed on [ __ ] ebay
are you [ __ ] nuts why would you write
that [ __ ] you know that's not true yeah
but this is what i'm saying and i expect
people who are in
high political power to be smarter than
that
right like i said i don't really have a
side
right this is why me i'm very like kind
of in the middle about
oh no i have a side on this matter i
know for sure but when i see this it's
like
how can you just how can you when you
have a public platform
right you know that either you're a
correspondent for whatever political
view that you have
you can openly say these stupid things
that are clearly not true all it takes
is one google search
right for you to say that the the
looting in walmart and target are rights
and this
isn't blows my [ __ ] mind they found
bombs a [ __ ] cop was
murdered with a [ __ ] fire
extinguisher for crying out loud
right they were destroying the place
wrecking it somebody broke into
uh pelosi's office started taking photos
in there yeah which that motherfucker's
in jail now yeah
you know well i mean there's a there's a
big investigation
to find the people that they're looking
for oh because this stuff just doesn't
happen no for sure
and there was clips of cops just letting
them write the [ __ ] on through
and taking selfies with with some of
these people so that makes you think
like oh this is how deep does it go with
this [ __ ] you know what i wonder i
really do want yeah
um and and the crazy [ __ ] about it is is
like the comparisons that
these people are making like look i'm
not saying
the writing and looting stores and small
businesses right by any means
you know that's wrong my family's been
on the receiving end of that
first so for sure i i have a gripe with
that
but this is a different level this is
an attack on the country and the
government
and like our core principle like what
the country is built on top of
and they want to compare this to like
riding in the streets
yeah exactly that's apples and oranges
yeah this is this is
way worse yeah i know people want to say
like they're both the same and it's not
it is absolutely not yeah they
made they showed a huge weakness
number one in our national security that
right there for me as an american
is frightening you have to understand
what that makes us
look like as a country that a bunch of
hillbillies
climbing a wall they just went right the
[ __ ] on into the cap that's all it took
well you know what add another one to
the [ __ ] list
you know with how things have gone in
2020
and now things bleeding over into 2021
right
i mean trump hasn't exactly
done a good job of making america a
leader you know
and making america look like the country
that it's always been
um so it's just add another one to the
list man
watching people trying to climbing the
wall in the capitol was one of the
funniest things i've ever seen in my
life
i feel like there was just these bunch
of white people just climbing it up
saying i told you walls don't work
we could climb this [ __ ] easy baby
that's what i'm saying man like the
irony of the whole situation is just
perfect
you know it's i mean and what a [ __ ]
terrible tragedy
but also what a perfect ending to like
the the end of trump's presidency kind
of like the the culmination of it being
a second impeachment too yeah um
and so man it's it's been a really
really like draining and exhausting and
disheartening and i'm so curious because
obviously on this channel there's a
bunch of people who are trolls
especially the way i'm going to title
this there there are people who are
hyper pro
trump hyper right wing hyper pro
republican that are coming there that
are going to come in and say something
that's fine which is fine
we're just going to they're usually not
fans of this channel it's people who
who just have to say their piece yeah
they have to infiltrate put their piece
in right which is going to be so
because i want to know like in my
personal opinion i
the first impeachment a lot of people
felt like it was a reach on both sides
right but i can understand that this
second one i want to hear what they're
going to say
because it's televised what he said it's
literally recorded yeah
about his words that caused an
insurrection so
what the [ __ ] is somebody going to say
it's justified they're going to say it's
justified what he said
because there is widespread voter fraud
yeah
they're gonna say it's justified i mean
that's what they're falling back on i
mean
that's that is the core idea behind
everything that's happening right now
and you know what you got guys like rudy
giuliani you got guys like trump
you got guys like trump jr who are just
provoking these people yeah you know
just spreading [ __ ]
absolute lies and falsehoods and and
firing these people up
and it's like yes shame on the people
for getting
fooled like that but also more so shame
on the people who are in the position
of power and have a platform to reach a
lot of people
to do this type i mean it's just
absolutely despicable
you know and i [ __ ] hope that trump's
ass
spends the rest of his life in jail
after after he's out of office
um because it doesn't look like he's
gonna be you know
forced out of office before inauguration
yeah
it's it's pretty unlikely but i do hope
man
that these uh investigations that are
going on
um lands his ass in jail because that's
what he [ __ ] deserves
oh dude they would love his fat ass dude
like i'm talking about he got
the juiciest ass of all presents
presidents that has ever existed that's
got a dunk on him dude he does that
focus his proportion is strange just
[ __ ]
he has this weird like lean yeah you got
that michael jackson
yeah i don't know how he does it it's
like a magic trick but he got that kim k
booty in the back
that guy is oh man it's weird man like i
i feel like the state of this country is
getting worse and worse
especially because now we're also
dealing with this and then we're dealing
with covet as well
like the california covet case situation
is is
it's really disheartening you know it's
unbelievable man
and um and i'm probably i'd probably
address it as far as multiple times on a
podcast but i'ma just keep saying it
again like
people don't really understand how scary
this virus can be
yeah right and i understand like listen
i'm with you on the stuff that most
people are going to survive this right
but from my personal perspective and i'm
pretty sure that a lot of people have
this perspective as well
in the 32 years i've been alive right i
have never
ever ever known one person that has died
from the flu
because people keep mentioning the flu
they go well more people get infected by
the flu or whatever
but i have never known anybody to die
from the flu and i could count
now on both hands how many people i know
through somebody else that has died yeah
from covid yeah so that's the alarming
part right
i know people who have now had memory
loss from it i know a buddy who can't
remember [ __ ] from three months ago
literally can't remember [ __ ] yeah even
now like it's been about a month and a
half
uh since i caught kovid uh i i'm still
exhausted as [ __ ] i've never had these
symptoms with the flu yeah like you know
me like i'm an insomniac yeah bro i'm
taking naps and [ __ ]
you just saw me chug the pepsi i'm still
sleepy yeah like this this this is like
some weird [ __ ] to me
you know like i'm not i still don't feel
the same my brain is still kind of foggy
like this
it's just such a novel virus and people
just don't want to take it seriously
and i'm on the side with a lot of
business owners who are suffering like i
get it for sure but everybody does have
to play their part so we can go ahead
and just get rid of this [ __ ] as fast as
possible
yeah i i don't know like i don't know
the answers to this but
nobody does nobody i mean but but that's
the thing is like
there is a level of uh sense
and reason though right of like what
seems like a practical approach or
not practical approach but like
practical things to do
um versus things that are not so
practical
and the scariest [ __ ] about this thing
is is you don't know how it's going to
affect you
you don't yeah it's a it's a gamble
exactly and why would you want to roll
the dice on that
why would you run why would you run like
it's one thing if you're [ __ ] betting
it on red or black in vegas
yeah not on your [ __ ] life though if
you care that little about your life and
other people's lives
then [ __ ] please walk around
without a mask into crowded areas
like this [ __ ] bruce wallace
yeah bruce willis bruce willis yeah
this [ __ ] really want to die
hard you know you know
you know i didn't even know that uh
twitter was uh or twitter
banned trump from their platform twitter
facebook uh
snapchat like this this guy is on a roll
you guys take away my snapchat how am i
gonna send my dick pics
exactly i had no idea well
because you know when in in terms of
like looking up a lot of the stuff there
was a huge concern people were talking
about
like um online or internet censorship
and how sometimes it's going too far
and the one of the videos that i saw and
i had to look this up too
uh only because when i heard this i
thought it was really stupid because
people were talking about it was
an infringement on a freedom of speech
no because
i was a private company exactly so
that's what i was thinking i was like
isn't that a private company because i
think from what i remember from high
school
i think that only applies to uh
government uh restricting your freedom
of speech so i actually had to look it
up just in case yeah before i said it on
this podcast
but let me just read something out to
people and once again this isn't
this this is kind of get going to get
kind of murky because obviously the
constitution was written since the the
beginning of this country so the
internet wasn't there at the time so
there might be changes to this later on
who really [ __ ] knows but uh
i read so university of florida um
a professor uh clay calvert is a law
professor at the university of florida
um and he says the constitution actually
is irrelevant here in terms of
the banning of public officials
including president trump from twitter
and that's because the first amendment
of the united states constitution only
protects us from government censorship
not censorship by private entities such
as twitter exactly
facebook or social media platforms so
you know it's a little bit off in terms
of the constitutional
issue that's involved here so if you
read the actual part of the constitution
it says that congress shall make no law
respecting an establishment of religion
or prohibiting the free exercise thereof
or bridging the freedom of speech or the
press
or the right of the people peaceably
peaceably to assemble and
and to petition the government for a
redress of grievances so specifically
congress so they're talking about
a government entity right because this
is a private entity it doesn't
they can do whatever the [ __ ] they want
exactly it's like i get upset at tick
tock all the time
because my tick tock is being taken down
like that's why i haven't been able to
pop off on that platform
like every time i curse or i say an
opinion anything they take my [ __ ] down
so i'm like [ __ ] this out but i'm not
over here you know saying like yo this
is my freedom of speech
i'm trying to teach these [ __ ]
three-year-old kids how to curse like
please let me get back on tick tock
this this concept is so interesting like
people and once again
the the the stuff that i read on twitter
wasn't from some layman
it was somebody who was in the political
realm that has that blue check mark on
it and they said that this is an
infringement
of the of president trump's
constitutional rights and i'm like
aren't you in the political space how do
i know this
a layman and you don't know this exactly
blows my mind not to [ __ ] mention is
like
bro he's the president of the
[ __ ] united states
he has every single news media outlet he
can speak to people
in masses blows my mind he doesn't need
[ __ ] twitter he doesn't need facebook
he doesn't need snapchat
he has the [ __ ] news outlets
yeah
if if he would be willing to you know
give him the time of day
yeah but he he thinks they're the enemy
of the [ __ ] state
and the enemy of the people but this guy
does not need those platforms
you communicate you're good he's just a
[ __ ] idiot
that's the problem that's the [ __ ]
problem at first two i remember when he
was tweeting out stuff i
used to think to myself like yo man this
full got a funny-ass ghostwriter
right this is just him this is a funny
parody yeah
i was like yo man this dude got somebody
riding some funny ass [ __ ]
like he knows what he's doing and then
when
as the president of the united states he
starts addressing people through his
speeches and all these public platforms
where it's him standing and words coming
out of his [ __ ] mouth i'm like
oh [ __ ] he's writing this himself like
this is just him
you know what i wish this [ __ ]
would do though that he would create
these uh
[ __ ] ghost accounts oh i
wish you would do that dude i once saw
president trump's dong
it was huge it was amazing it was
tremendous i love it tremendous
and him trying to get back on the
platform you know
i i wish he would do that dude friggin
um
there was an article that i read um and
i got a little disappointed
and a little angry because so i guess
out in florida
you know what a manatee is right yeah
manatee they're like yeah yeah the fresh
water
seawater first one i think it's fresh
water are they fresh water [ __ ] i don't
even [ __ ] know but they're like cute
little
little little mini elephants in the
water yeah yeah yeah and they just huge
they're i mean they're still pretty big
they're not the size of them yeah yeah
yeah but they're like one of the most
gentle creatures ever but i guess some
trump
uh supporters they scabbed up a manatee
and they wrote trump on its back
why i don't know what the [ __ ] is the
symbolism behind that
like and who the [ __ ] was gonna say this
like your support of trump on a [ __ ]
man
how did you even [ __ ] catch it first
of all well there's really slow like if
you
swim because when i went to florida i
saw people just go next to a manatee and
they just float next to you
they're that [ __ ] gentle wow you just
float next to them
why would you do that i don't know what
i there's so many questions there
i don't like the color of this manatee
it's not wide enough
from all day [ __ ] now spread it
to your friends
get out there now you tell your little
left-wing manatee friends
about our lord and savior trump
hallelujah please let him go
oh yeah like i was shocked i'm like yo
but then i felt like more people were
upset about the manatee than they were
about the
the storming of the capital and i'm like
yo everybody's priorities are [ __ ] up
right now i don't know what's going on
dude
united states when trump came into
office
actually turned into a [ __ ] reality
show you know it is
it really is yeah and like i i just i
just reflect back
on like the past four years especially
this past year
and i'm like i can't i can't believe
this has been real life man
it's it's it's just it's [ __ ] wild
and ridiculous
yeah well the the positive thing about
this too hopefully
is that people are going to understand
how important it is
when it comes to media facets and what
they say and how they write things
right because it's been going on for a
while now and people have to get smart
to this [ __ ] about what they read and
how people sensationalize things
even for the side that i enjoy like
sometimes i read these titles and i'm
like are you here
to objectively tell the truth about what
happened or are you here to get people
angry and mad
because the way you write things are
[ __ ] people up right
like some people will just read a title
alone and they'll go
on this political tirade even though
they haven't read everything
yeah and it's and it's it just shows how
[ __ ] dumb people are still they still
don't understand
that it's gonna take for you to as an
adult to read things thoroughly
and process things even if you don't
agree with the side right you still have
to know what's going on for you to form
somewhat of an opinion and i'm not
telling people to be experts but i'm
saying that if you are going to go on
facebook
on these tirades with with no base or
foundation to anything that they're
saying besides their feelings and i you
know look
look i get it i'm one of them
[ __ ] too you know i've i've
definitely done that multiple times in
the guise of comedy i understand
but for example even this title that i
read right is talking about the the
police officer the officer that was
killed
it's a terrible tragedy right but even
the way they titled this
he dreamed of being a police officer
then was killed by a pro-trump mob
like you know what you're doing when you
wrote that right like you're trying to
get people pissed off
and that's not what we need triggering
people yeah for sure
um and and i mean but that's that's kind
of like the
the age we're in though right yeah with
clickbait titles because that's that's
what they're going for they're trying to
get clicks
they want to trigger people because
that'll get them views that'll
that'll get people to share the articles
or share the tweet
whatever the case is yeah like youtube
fun videos
instagram whatever that's fine yeah
that's based in the world of
entertainment like mr b
saying i'm gonna give fifty thousand
dollars to and he actually does it
yeah so like that's cool makes sense
yeah you know but when we're talking
about news outlets right
i even had a problem with this like
and i had to think about this when trump
became president and i'm not sure people
remember this but it was i think it was
cnn
who's what what uh media outlet is don
lemon a part of
cnn he's a part of cnn right and
i understand the sentiment but if you
guys remember this years ago maybe i'll
even put this clip up it might still be
on the internet but when trump became
president right
and don lemon had to announce it don
lemon
like rolled his eyes and he was like
trump is president and i'm like
bro you are a news outlet
leave those emotions at the door just
report it you got to be objective you
have to be objective that is your job i
agree with him
right but seeing that from a viewer's
perspective it's like for sure
for sure responsibility yeah like be a
little more responsible with the [ __ ]
that you do journalistic integrity right
exactly and that's that's the fault on
both sides that i see
absolutely absolutely and it's really
starting to piss me off it's like when
the [ __ ] are we just going to
just get information you know it is not
your job to put
your own political bias when you say
when you are part of a
news station yeah you know yeah i mean
but yeah bias
obviously exists on both sides but
i guess the thing that's
most discouraging about like progress on
that front
is you look at how divided the country
is right now yeah that's not gonna
change anytime soon
that's not gonna go away because a new
president is coming into office
those same people are still gonna be
here one year from now
two years from now ten years from now
and as long as that's the case
there's always gonna be a sense of
division now
a guy like trump is gonna really
exaggerate that division
right make it more prominent make it
feel like
yes there's group it's like black and
white oil and water
these people are never gonna mesh it's
either my side or that side
um and and and to an extent like that's
kind of what the country has always been
right uh it's just that there won't be
as much
clashing or as much fighting within
where you stand politically based on
kind of like the circumstances of the
country but
this guy was instigator a provoker
and he just kept feeling that fire to
the point where like
people started acting thinking
more emotionally than logically and
reasonably
and you know the people on
the right there are definitely
reasonable people
that there are very reasonable
republican but there are
also these [ __ ] that need to be
held accountable
these people in office these senators
right
who before trump came into office
was telling a very different story about
how damaging he would be
guys like lindsey graham that
[ __ ] i hate that
i hate that [ __ ] guy the most
i [ __ ] i hate his guts cause he's such a
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] you know uh guys
like ted cruz
right um even even the uh the white
house uh
what do you call her like the uh the
speaker or uh
though i forgot what the official title
is uh mac and nanny
whatever her name is yeah right yeah
yeah they've all been on record publicly
basically denouncing trump oh for sure
yeah talking about
how bad he would be for the united
states how terrible yeah and how bad
they would be for the republican party
and then you got these dick suckers who
like that and and and now they're
pro-trump because
they care about their party exactly well
their party and their career
yeah but more so their career yeah it's
their political interest like that's
and that that can not be [ __ ]
forgotten by the people because the
people have the power to put them and
keep them there
they need to be [ __ ] held accountable
just because now here at the tail end
you got the gop starting to turn their
back on trump because now he's like a
cancer to them
yeah and it's hurting them it's costing
them votes and seats now
yeah now they're saying we got to just
get rid of this guy like mitch mcconnell
for example
right but
the people the everyday people who have
the power of the vote
and and and legitimate votes not not
this
not this [ __ ] story of uh election
fraud right
because here's here's the crazy [ __ ]
about that is
how can some of these people who are on
the same [ __ ] ticket
argue about there was major voter fraud
when they won when they won yeah
it's like oh so you're basically saying
your [ __ ] win was fraudulent then
yeah cause they're dumb as [ __ ] exactly
that's that's what i'm saying like
the [ __ ] amount of like
energy you need to spend to just kill
your brain cells
to just squash it to get to that
conclusion
or or if you were to say that
they're actually reasonably intelligent
people they know exactly what they're
doing
what's worse you know what i mean yeah
it's knowing it
and and knowingly misleading people
knowingly spreading misinformation
especially when you're a public servant
they're supposed to serve the public
and and the weird thing about this
election too even when biden won
and i'm pretty sure a lot of people have
this uh a similar sentiment to this
biden winning didn't feel like a
a victory because the right president
was elected
right it felt like a victory because
we're trying to get this [ __ ] yeah
it's like a consolation prize almost
right yeah because i'll be 100 honest
with you yeah
i don't know much about biden i just
know he's not trump
you know and i know that i just didn't
want this
to me this psychopath to become the
president of the united states
imagine another four more years of that
[ __ ] dude i mean it's insane too that
biden's campaign was literally
you don't want this guy to be president
that was his whole campaign really that
easy though
yeah really that easy right like that
speaks for itself yeah you don't need to
say anything else
if you if you have any sense of like
reason in you
you see that and that resonates with you
like yeah you're [ __ ] right
i don't want any more of this [ __ ] i
don't want this [ __ ] dominating
my life all the time
dominating the headlines always
something about him oh
like i've never seen a president in the
news more than this guy
ever ever i've never seen so many people
talk about a president more than this
guy and and i guess
uh that's a credit to his his uh
branding abilities
right his genius yeah um but
enough is enough man it's it's it's been
absolutely [ __ ] exhausting and and
one thing that comes to mind
is when trump became the president uh
back in 2016
there were people who there was that
popular
kind of uh theme of he is not my
president oh that's right
there was that there was that there were
people who were saying
we do not acknowledge him as the
president okay that's fine
but was there violence as a result of it
was there was there an attack as a
result of no
you're practicing your free that's what
freedom of speech is yeah right
no but it's like at the end of the day
you can say that but yet he is your
president there's no getting away around
it
you could you could you're free to
express your your feelings and your
sentiment about it
but legally he is the president he's
been elected into office
i don't even know how that one girl
what's her name tommy lauren i don't
know how she even
has such a huge platform this girl's
literally the dumbest [ __ ]
ever because she she she says things so
confidently
um and and like there's a base of people
that it resonates [ __ ] flat ass [ __ ]
i hate her so much i mean she's [ __ ]
annoying she's really obnoxious
people have been [ __ ] roasting her
ass because she wrote this very specific
tweet saying that
um when if donald trump wins
or or doesn't win it's going to be
peaceful unlike the left that will
riot and i'm like what in the [ __ ]
are you talking about you know but she
says these things as like
with with because she's like an
absolutist like oh this is absolutely
what's going to happen
like in her mind this is how how things
are going to play out yeah
and she doesn't it's kind of weird it's
like how do people look at her and say
this is an intelligent human being
here's the thing though i think people
like that actually know exactly what
they're doing
oh i think i think they're very clear on
their intention
like they have an agenda and they're
doing everything
in their power humanly possible to
execute on that agenda which is
to have a platform to be known and and
make money you make money
right and and as long as this gets like
a new strata coven i i pray
like one that's specific specifically
for her
and and and it's like and a lot of those
people i feel like
now look there there are the cuckoo
heads for sure that are off in their own
world just like kind of living in almost
an alternate reality right
there are those type of people too but i
also firmly believe
there's just as many if not more people
who know exactly what they're doing
there's no uh misconception or no like
um disconnect in their mind of like oh
what i'm doing is wrong or right it's
there is no wrong or right though the
only thing that matters is
do i get something out of this yeah is
there something to gain is there self
benefit
she is literally like how she conducts
herself and the things that she says
it's literally for her own benefit she
is the most like definitively to me she
is the most
unpatriotic person ever because she
would rather watch this country
go into turmoil and burn in the guise of
her thinking that she's doing it for
this country
she is literally a she's uh what's the
word i'm looking for
somebody who's against this country
she's a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
anarchist well that's how i see it
anyways right because if it's true that
she's doing this stuff for self-profit
because she knows it's going to piss
people off and even if she has like an
ounce of reason she's clearly saying
things to
make people upset so it's like come on
man you are
the most un-american person i've ever
never met controversial for the sake of
being controversial because it sells
yeah because it gets clicks because it
gets
uh views um and there's plenty of people
in new media out she ain't even cute
people talking about she cute
what the [ __ ] are you talking about the
most basic white [ __ ] i've ever seen in
my life
especially like she was born out of a
waterfall out of a hairy [ __ ]
i mean she's she's i mean um you know to
her credit though
she did go on the trevor noah show and
and they did have kind of like a little
mini debate on there
um and and then like she'll do debates
with like people on the other side
and and it's like when when i watch
those things it just [ __ ]
blows my mind not in a good way um
but again it gets her attention it gets
her views it brings
like stirs the pot and that's what she's
doing people like her and she's not
alone in doing that there's there's a
lot of
and i'm gonna call them culprits you
know um who who do that type of [ __ ]
and look man it's working for them right
we're talking about her
right it's it's playing to her agenda
whether you're supporting her or not as
long as her name and her brand
yeah she got you guys she got it just
please
god if you listen god this is 20 21 i
just pray just give her some
a new strand of kobe by one that you
can't beat
at all like give her a strand of code
that'll turn her black
so she knows what it's like to be a
[ __ ] black american in america oh man
she'll wake up every morning look in her
mirror and then [ __ ] say racial
epithets to her face
[ __ ] [ __ ] speaking of speaking of
that you know being a black person in
america the
the [ __ ] about me uh what was it mia
ponzero
that 22 year old who accused that 14
year old kid of stealing her phone
you didn't see that no what's that oh my
god so
i think it was it happened at like a
hotel and um basically this [ __ ]
uh mia she like goes ham on this 14 year
old black kid
and accuses him of stealing her phone
and and like
charges after him and luckily the kid's
dad is there
and like he's stopping her like and
they're confused like what what are you
talking and he's like
and she's basically saying she's
convinced absolutely certain
this kid stole my phone like that is my
and the
and the dad is like is is there only you
know one kind of iphone that exists in
the world like
i everybody has iphones this this one is
his he did not steal your phone
uh i have a huawei yeah long story short
though
it turned out that she actually left her
phone in an uber and the uber driver had
to bring it
back all you have to do is turn on a
screen to show you it's not your phone
[ __ ]
but but she was convinced and and then
like you know um
the the controversy behind it is that
obviously
the whole racial profiling you know that
that's what she did
but it'd be one thing if she came out
and was
genuine in her apology but this [ __ ]
had the audacity to give sass
in in her apology you know um well
he's black yeah so it's just
you know just another one of those kind
of incidents where it's like
hey don't say that there is uh there
isn't inequality in this country that
there isn't racial profiling this [ __ ]
happens all the [ __ ] time no i hear
that [ __ ] dude it just reminds me of
that kid
who i think he he committed suicide in
the jail cell because he was
he was accused of stealing a backpack
you heard about that right
well this was like a while ago a long
time ago right
but man i really wish i could remember
this name actually i'm gonna look it up
and i'll put it in the
i'll put it in the actual video i don't
want to [ __ ] this up but the kid got
accused for stealing a backpack
and he got put to like like alcatraz or
something oh my god and
he didn't steal the backpack and then he
committed suicide in the jail
in prison that's i mean
you have you have so much um scenarios
where that type of thing happens
and it's it's it's sad man
it's [ __ ] up um and it just kind of
goes back to the point you were making
of like
when all this [ __ ] is going on at a
certain point man
it just [ __ ] with you mentally like
emotionally spiritually and you just
have to disconnect
you know oh this wasn't even it was like
in 2015 bro oh that's not that long ago
oh actually hold on that's when he died
i'm sorry uh
let's see so it's khalif broder that's
what it is and it was going around for
us so
khalif brother was an african-american
youth from the bronx new york
who was held at rikers island jail
complex without trial between 2010 and
2013 for allegedly stealing a backpack
containing valuables during his
imprisonment broder was in solitary
confinement for two [ __ ]
why is he in solitary confinement i
don't know two years after his release
broder hanged himself at his parents
home
oh my god his case has been cited by
activists campaigning for reform of the
new york city criminal justice system
and has attracted widespread attention
in the years following his death
that's [ __ ] sad man isn't that
[ __ ] sad dude that is
but i mean you know it's one of many
right
one of many [ __ ] countless cases like
that
throughout the country when you hear
about a case like that you're thinking
like oh this must have happened like in
the 60s
you know right right like how like has
time
really stood still for when it comes to
like equal rights for people of color
what i start to really think about
and i think for people who haven't grown
up around this community and had
and they haven't really seen this like
first at hand
it's it's hard for them to understand
right because they live in a world
where the law is always on their side
when something [ __ ] up they call the
police
they call the cops over the cops are on
their
side so it's hard for them to process
and i have to understand and be
empathetic with that to a certain degree
yeah because for me before the internet
i thought every asian kid's experience
was like my asian
experience so why when i would hear
asian people online complain about
oh you know people look at asian men
like they're not really manly and [ __ ]
and i'm like maybe you because you're a
[ __ ]
but then but then i find i listen to
their story yeah and it turns out that
one or two asian kid in all
in all of high school right and that was
their only exposure to asian people was
was him in high school they did the
[ __ ] eye [ __ ] to him they
emasculated him make fun of him yeah so
you know i was very dismissive of what
certain individuals would go to because
i didn't experience it so same with
these people
and what you should do is what i did is
just listen
yeah there has to be some sort of truth
to this if there's a majority of people
saying the same thing
unless you think it's some type of
conspiracy where [ __ ] every
the millions of people um who are
african-american or black american
or asian-american mexican-american or
whatever are all in this together
just to say [ __ ] you to every single
white person in this country like
there has to be some type of truth or
that you have to listen to it at least
at least give somebody the respect to
tell their story and then you can decide
whether it's true or not right
right but to outright tell somebody [ __ ]
you because i didn't go through it or i
don't experience it then when i called
the cop
that in my reality yeah so that can't be
reality exactly right that's kind of the
uh
the idea behind that but it's like dude
this [ __ ] has been going on for decades
and decades and decades
like if you are the un
under the impression that there is no
truth to this right i'm not saying that
every single case is
you know a case that shouldn't have
happened but there's a good chunk of it
that shouldn't have happened the way it
did
it's like you can't dismiss that you
can't look at that and be like
yeah uh i've never personally seen that
in my life
well what kind of people are you around
are you are you around
like the same group in the same kind of
like
social and economic standing right let
me tell you this quick story man like
when when the whole blm stuff started
happening and you know i was very vocal
about it because obviously it's a
community that
i've been around for a majority of my
life so i understand
my best friend is black you know so when
we
i had this conversation with somebody
and it was a korean person
and for them they live in a very
secluded area
they don't really have much friends out
there and their community is their small
little church community
and that's really about it right so
their perspective of what they see
is only with the few select people that
they have around you which is a very
it's very closed-minded right
but in their mind how they see things is
that oh i don't just listen to news fast
and because i'm away from everything
i actually see things with a lot more
clarity than most people
and so the conversation came up where
this person this dude said
uh he was talking about blackface right
he goes he goes well there's a there's a
line to where blackface can be offensive
and where it can't be offensive and i
looked at him i was like well
how come you're you as an asian person
why are you defining that
it's not your community so how how can
you define that in your place
and so the the thing that they were kind
of mentioning was like okay well
this person for halloween did blackface
this was years before i who
i knew this person was right and i'm not
getting angry i just have to hear the
story
because as a comic i'm like this is
about to be the most [ __ ] up thing i'm
about to hear in my life
let me hear what you're going to say
right so this person wanted to dress up
as kanye west
so no i'm not
i can't make this [ __ ] up right and look
i'm not bashing on this person because
what they were saying is like i
understood what they were saying right
and once again this is somebody has to
go just going back to what i was saying
before
is somebody who didn't grow up around
the black community
at all right but has a very very staunch
position and opinion
about how this community should conduct
and behave themselves when it comes to
stuff that offends them
yeah which is [ __ ] stupid right so
halloween dresses up as kanye west
shares it with the church group or
whatever right
there was one person that was offended
i'm not sure if that person was black or
white or whatever
say hey yo this is a little offensive
and their argument to that was
like well this isn't me doing blackface
i'm trying to look like kanye west the
artist
and that's what their thing was and
they're like okay i was like well here
let me explain this to you then all
right
for you to do that i understand where
you're coming from
however in order for you to do something
like that you're also being extremely
dismissive of what is
what has happened in this country it's
history you cannot
erase history especially with stuff
that's happening in this country now and
things haven't really changed as much as
we thought it did
yeah you're being very ignorant to the
social climate and you're telling people
not to be offended stuff because your
intent was in the right place
but you're also being dismissive of how
people feel about the history
and about how stuff like this is still
happening till this day blackface
is is not the same you are in the united
states of america
yeah there are repercussions to the
stuff that you do specifically when it
comes to
you imitating this specific culture in
this country
and i was trying to get this person to
understand that to me it's very obvious
right but to them it's not and so what
they said is like well i would be okay
if somebody you know dressed up as an
asian person and
it was it was and it looked they were
wearing the right stuff and it looked
like an
asian like they somebody dressed up as
lisa ling from uh
kill bill is what they said i was like
cool now imagine that
they're doing the the lisa ling thing
right perfect whatever
but they get tape exactly and they pull
them out
all the way the [ __ ] back yeah
right yeah is it still accurate or does
it offend you
right and the person paused yeah and
they go
i can see why that would be offensive
i'm like
so you do understand there you go you do
understand because you're making a
caricature of this culture right
right and just because and they said
like well when i did i showed my friend
who's a black
who's a black person and they said that
it was fine you're one black person
doesn't represent every black person in
this country and also too on top of that
i was like
if i looked at your yearbook and your
photo book and a rolodex of your history
in your life
i bet you i could count on the fingers
of my one single hand
how many black friends you have in your
life how many black people you've been
around
how much that culture has been around
you that is how
little you've been incorporated into
that culture but look at how
big your opinion is about how they
should conduct themselves
if somebody did that to you about korean
culture how offended would you be about
that
yeah what if i told you when
when let's say like uh i don't know um
we were still under japan's uh uh um
rule
right but they gave us like independence
or whatever they allowed us to speak or
whatever right
and this might be a little hyperbolic um
an example right
but somebody told you well that was
years ago why are you still upset about
it
you know would you be okay with that you
probably [ __ ] wouldn't yeah it would
be the same thing as when somebody sits
here
and they try to tell you as a
korean-american about korean culture
and how you should feel about other
people imitating korean culture and
you know doing whatever they want about
it and having an opinion you would feel
the same you're not seeing things
through an empathetic lens
you're just trying to defend the point
that you had a costume and you liked it
yeah i mean it comes from ignorance
though right yeah yeah it's not that
they had ill
intent but that doesn't yell at them
yeah yeah that doesn't excuse their
behavior in action but you know you
definitely took them down the right path
and trying to show them
why this can be perceived as very
offensive yeah and i think i only broke
through like ten percent
this was like a two-hour conversation
though that's the start yeah
plant the seed yeah as long as they're
willing to have the conversation
and try to keep somewhat of an open mind
that's all you can really ask for yeah
right
and as long as it doesn't escalate into
like uh
like a b for like an argument or
whatever and you guys can talk
just in a civil way in reasonable way
mature way
that's that's all you can really hope
for man yeah and you know they
understood 10
that's that's all i could ask for it was
just like i just remember having these
conversations consistently
with a lot of people that i i mean
they're not homey homies you know but
they're like on the periph
the peripheral right so like the
periphery i'm sorry and
it's kind of weird and that's where i
had to kind of check myself and say like
ah that's because i grew up in a
different neighborhood so they're not
gonna know
these things that are innately in me now
because i've just been around the black
community my parents own a black beauty
supply store
i went to a predominantly black church
for like seven eight years of my life
you know my best friends
so yeah of course these things are gonna
be uh
it's gonna be uh i'm more knowledgeable
to this stuff than you are
you're more socially aware yeah yeah you
know and there's stuff that i'm not
socially aware about when it comes to
other people's culture so i could only
hope that somebody gives me that same
grace
which is why in that conversation but
that's the thing though is that
once once you kind of have like that
uh foundation for understanding certain
things
right you wouldn't overstep those
boundaries you know what i mean just
because
like let's say you understand one
culture better than the other
but you're not gonna do something that
you might
that that might ring as something that
possibly could be offensive or possibly
might be something where you're stepping
over the line because you have that
sensitivity already yeah built into you
you know what i mean
versus if you don't have that compass
guide you
then it's just kind of free-for-all
right it's like well
i didn't mean anything wrong by it but
it's like
well it is wrong though yeah because you
should recognize that yeah right
and for you to tell people not to be
offended by it when it's something that
doesn't affect you on a personal scale
yeah it's odd to me it's a little
insensitive yeah not even on a race
issue just for any type of stuff that
you're going to deal with
later on in the future if that's how you
deal with it it's basically you
consistently saying
this is how i feel [ __ ] you yeah you
know like i give a perfect example for
that that you know since we were
speaking about the asian thing it'd be
like
a group of people walking into an asian
person's home right
and let's say you have no familiarity
with how asians are in the house in
their household
and you see a group of people taking off
their shoes and you see that and you
recognize that
but you decide ah [ __ ] it and you just
wear my shoes yeah and you just keep
walking in
like you didn't necessarily have an
illite ill intent there
you know you it can be excuses i didn't
know but
also you're not paying attention to the
science there either yeah you know
it's like if if everybody's kind of
doing that there must be some
significance
to that yeah right you don't want to do
that with me i'll [ __ ] your [ __ ] up dude
i would literally chop your [ __ ]
feet off the moment you [ __ ] was like
oh you want to do the widest thing then
i'll do the most chinese thing on earth
i'm gonna go to your dining table i'm
gonna put my foot up like this
and i'm gonna chew with my mouth open
like you [ __ ] [ __ ] let's play this
game
let's play the [ __ ] culture battle
game right now i will [ __ ] your [ __ ] up
i will pee in a bottle and leave it at
your doorstep
you [ __ ] i'm a country rule
asian [ __ ] dude
play that game with me yeah it's that
was the weird part i think last year was
me just having to have these
conversations a lot right
and um i uh i remember this conversation
i had with kid at a college
and this was highly disappointing and it
was a little
i want to say obnoxious but it's it kind
of highlighted
uh an issue that i think that i tend
that i was ignoring a lot because i
never saw it in front of me
but there was a kid at a college and
i've addressed this before multiple
times on a podcast
when i grew up i used to say the n word
profusely
that was my [ __ ] i used to end every
sentence with it you know
that's just how everybody spoke in
sacramento bay area everybody knows too
in the bay area it's still like that
till this day yeah for me because i'm on
a socially conscious platform now
i don't really care to say it anymore
it's not really a big deal i'm not what
am i going to fight for that [ __ ]
it's like no like every now and then if
i'm drunk it's going to slip out
but i'm going to check myself though
right so
when this kid asked me at a college show
he goes hey david like you grew up with
a lot of black people and stuff like
that you know like it's all
you know and like you know i feel like
hip hop culture is so uh
it's widespread now because of music and
stuff like you know and i grew up you
know
like in an area where there was like
black and mexican people too because i
but you became
if i said you know the n-word right and
i'm like no
i looked at him i was like no yeah why
would you ask me that yeah
i was like number one two i'm not your
black ambassador yeah exactly
i don't got a pass that i could just
handle
do i have this [ __ ] uh [ __ ] uh
coachella yeah
take it for you your golden ticket buddy
yeah now you're good
it was such a weird if you're listening
to this podcast that's one of the
dumbest [ __ ] things you ever asked me
you could have ever asked anybody and so
when i heard that [ __ ] i was kind of
like
what do these kids expect and what is
your tie to this word
that you feel that you that you have a
right to say it
right again ignorance bro ignorance and
then why ask me
and i bet you too you would have never
asked a black person you asking me
because you think i'm safe
i'm not the safe one yeah that's a dumb
question yeah
if if if a culture even within that
culture is
kind of confused about the usage of the
word maybe that's something that we
should just [ __ ] off with like just
let them figure it out that's their
thing it's there's a lot of pain
towards it right tim told a great story
uh to me a while ago and i'm pretty sure
he told it on his podcast but he he said
he used to say it a lot too
and there was a moment when he went into
the bathroom
to my bed if i'm telling you a story but
if i'm butchering it but he said that
there was a time where he was in a
bathroom and there was these two white
kids in a stall
and they were saying the n-word crazy
like like a machine gun
you know and there was an older black
gentleman in the in the bathroom too
and he just you know tim and him kind of
made eyes with each other and
you know the idea was kind of irritating
he kind of shook his head like the [ __ ]
you know and he kind of left
and tim was shaking his head too but
then he stopped for a second he was like
well i'm them too yeah i'm guilty too
yeah and this is when he was super young
and from then on he just
stopped saying the word yeah right um
but that just kind of goes to show it's
like where is our place
in this in this culture and society
because i think the the hard part for a
lot of people
um is that if they feel like sometimes
and once again i'm just speaking from my
personal perspective that people are
taking
you're taking all the positive without
taking the negative yeah right like
how come you get to have all this
culture that we built up through
being uh oppressed right yeah and then
you get all the benefits
and when it comes down to helping us out
you're like that's your problem
you just [ __ ] off i mean appropriation
at its finest right yeah
this sucks you know for sure so i mean
that's
that's uh definitely something um
that people should be more sensitive or
try to at least be more sensitive about
even if you haven't grown up in a
certain environment or whatever
being culturally sensitive is not that
hard if you just pay attention a little
bit you know that's all you got to
really do
and and if if by accident you are
overstepping your bounds and somebody
checks you on that
listen listen to it don't just
automatically get defensive and be like
no no i didn't mean anything buy it i'm
like i don't i didn't
i didn't mean to offend any but yeah
that might be the case but if you did
something that's offending somebody or a
group of people
chances are you [ __ ] up you know and
and it's a moment to be able to reflect
think about it learn and improve you
know what i mean and for like asian
americans out there it's like
you know like that uh like that one
white dude that you met he dated an
asian girl and suddenly he's like doing
asian accents
it's like bro i will stab you right here
on the spot i don't give a [ __ ] where
you put your dick
yeah you know what i mean exactly i will
gut you like a [ __ ] fish
get that [ __ ] out of my [ __ ] face
yeah you know same [ __ ]
you know and i'm pretty sure when you're
in those situations very odd and i've
been in those situations before
literally i'm telling you this as an
example that i've seen multiple times
where i had to check somebody
or this dude either grew up with like a
korean best friend
or a chinese best friend or dated some
[ __ ] chinese girl
and all of a sudden they're coming out
with like these russell peter jokes
right in front of my face
and i'm like hey bro i will [ __ ] you up
speaking of
chinese uh did you see recently that
alexander wayne got me tood
alexander are you talking about the the
designer yeah
yeah so there's been uh people who have
come out and spoken against them about
like how he's
um sexually abused them raped them um
yeah and this [ __ ] was quiet
for a few days and then uh he posted on
on his account that he's that he's
fighting against this now
now he's playing the victim card and
he's he got raped no no
he's saying i'm innocent oh that i did
nothing wrong
you know and that all these people are
just telling lies and
that they're gonna do everything in
their legal power to like hold them
accountable
and it's like what okay
it's not just one person coming out
there's there's multiple people coming
out right now
talking about this right yet all these
people who are friends
might might even have an endorsement
from him and you know maybe
their brand sponsors them whatever it's
kind of quiet
on the matter right oh that's when you
know this [ __ ] did some [ __ ]
it it's and it's like how do you
where do you draw the line with that you
know like i can understand
like for example if if i was a fan
of let's say i was just a huge fan of
alexander wing's
line and all the [ __ ] that he does but
then
if there's kind of uh enough things that
surface
where it comes into doubt my thing isn't
gonna be
yeah [ __ ] these fools who are saying
[ __ ] they're just slandering your name
i'm gonna be like ooh there might be
something here
yeah yeah right and i think
in his position he was probably trying
to think about
how should he respond to this if he
should respond at all
and then alexander wang is is gay yeah
okay yeah um so there's i don't want to
make an assumption but i know what
alexander wayne looks like yeah yeah
yeah
my man looked like yeah you know gay
luke yeah there's been there's been
um trans and and like you know gay
people coming out
saying you know that alexander wang
drugged them
you know did did some shady [ __ ] uh and
and it's like other people have been
around when these things were happening
um and like one person even kind of
alluded to the things that alexander
wang
uh has done and does do in jest right
just kind of like as a joke
and so there there had to have been like
some sort of awareness that this kind of
[ __ ] was going on
but it it kind of made me wonder too man
like
in in that world of like celebrities
just having that type of fame money and
power
like how much off
[ __ ] gets past his normalcy oh that's
just
him being him that's just her being her
oh yeah so what if he roofied
they just want to party and it's like
what do you mean so what yeah this
[ __ ] is trying to get this
person
to lose consciousness or or like
make poor decisions because their
judgment is off so they could take
advantage of them dude let me tell you
something i have gone to some
weird ass events in parties right where
i i've seen
people who look like they are soulless
human beings i'm not just saying this
just to add to this conversation
if you guys ever become in a position
where you you get to be
i would say i don't know you don't use
the word privy but you know you're
privy to all these type of like parties
and [ __ ] you'll see some of these weird
soulless [ __ ]
walk around and how they behave
themselves and the things that they do
yeah it's it's odd like for example like
here's something great
and i don't know what it is about i know
i'm a tribute i used to attribute this
to white people [ __ ] but i think it's
just people with money [ __ ]
they do stuff that's out of the social
norm but for some reason it's okay like
i've seen dudes like walk up to a girl
at a party and they kind of lightweight
know them they're like what
like what's up they're not gay it's not
a gay dude walking up and they just go
in and grab a tit and they're like oh
that's just him being him right i'm like
that's what i'm saying that's what i'm
saying the [ __ ] world wouldn't ever
be okay
but you know i feel like it's it's it's
such a um
foreign situation to be in because it's
like
the person is literally flexing their
power and their status
on you yeah their fame their wealth or
whatever and you
just being a normal ass person
you're not quite sure how to respond to
it yeah oh i guess it's okay
because he or she is and everybody else
is doing it yeah
and everybody else seems to just kind of
be cool with it so
maybe i'm just overreacting internal
like that it's that type of environment
you know what i mean
and so it's just like it just makes you
wonder how
rampant like this type of [ __ ] is
within that kind of elite community of
people
you know i mean money money talks like
oh yeah if you're a rich person yeah
and this is how they sometimes allow
people to do certain things because
number one
they are uncomfortable in that situation
they don't know anybody
right and number three they also know
that because and this is what people are
talking about why power is abused a lot
is because
it's also on the other hand the person
who who this happens to that knows that
they want something from this person
yeah yeah which i always tell people
it's like
hey [ __ ] all that stuff right like
keep your integrity yeah you know what i
mean yeah this person may have power and
they might be able to create opportunity
but you don't want it like that and
trust me it's going to [ __ ] you up
you know and because other people
normalize it within that group
they make that person feel bad for
feeling like a vic exactly
exactly and there might even be kind of
an instance of like
maybe you respect and admire this person
and then the fact that this person you
respect admire is showing you that kind
of attention
yeah oh he
grabbed my tits i i i guess i should
feel special
you know like i guess i should like that
they make you feel like you're a
buzzkill yeah you know what i mean
and i've been in those situations too
where for sure where some dudes like
because
you know how we grew up yeah i don't
[ __ ] know you don't touch me
you know like i've seen dude like in
these parties they're like what's up
look i'm friends with blah blah blah
cool
and this guy just comes up leans on my
shoulder starts talking to my ear yeah
and i stare at this dude with like a
death stare
like yo don't [ __ ] touch me bro you
know exactly you know
they feel the animosity but that's
normal that's some normal [ __ ] i'm sorry
in my world anyways you don't just grab
my [ __ ] and lean up on me with your
[ __ ] alcoholic breath in my ear right
brad i don't know you like that yeah you
know but again it's that environment
right
where it makes you second guess what
your instinct is saying that your
instinct is
is saying yo what the [ __ ] but then you
look around everyone's just kind of like
laughing and not even noticing what's
obnoxious hey
true story though first time i went to a
club i turned when i turned 18
right not not like on the day of but um
after i turned 18 there was this spot in
downtown
where they had like kind of like an
asian knight right and and for the asian
knight it was 18 and over
so you could get in and but then you get
like an x on your hand so you can't buy
alcohol
but you can get an 18 and over um it's
my first time
going to a club like a legit club and um
like they were chilling or whatever and
um
i started dancing with this girl and
then
two of her friends come over and then
they start getting
really [ __ ] freaky on me and then
like one of them starts like straight up
rubbing like grinding or [ __ ] on my leg
and then like few minutes into it one of
them straight up grabbed my dick
and i said uh hello
i and and then i bring this up because
it was like
i guess this [ __ ] happens like is this
normal yeah i guess this is not the odd
man out here yeah like
i'm not gonna say that i didn't like it
you know what i'm going to say
i'm 18 i got you know the the girls are
attractive and you know
but but it you know what i mean like
there is still that trigger where it's
like that's not normal
but then i second-guess myself because
i'm like i'm in an environment that i'm
not familiar with
and maybe this [ __ ] just kind of
happened i love clubbing
but let's look sometimes people on drugs
dude what the [ __ ] is going on
when i was at this bar once there was
one girl she was she was drunk as hell
and this is the most you know i look
back at it now especially because of
covet and sanitary reasons yeah i'm like
no this [ __ ] is nasty well now and then
is is
a different story like since covet is
it's allowed me to think about how many
filthy situations i've been in and it
was just completely okay like uh
[ __ ] it where was i was this in boston i
think i was in boston
i want to say boston young lady you were
very nice but
well i was very young too at the time so
we were on the same age but
we were uh we were on the dance floor
right and this girl
she was super touchy feely right but
this is the this has never ever happened
to me again before the only one time in
my life but this will
literally grab my hand and put it down
in her pants on the dance floor and she
wanted me to finger her on the dance
floor wow
right and i was like this woman is
amazing
but you know what though that's not like
too uncommon yeah because people are
drunk
you know i know for sure but yeah i've
never usually it's like i've i mean the
dick grab stuff happens people grinding
up on each other yeah
but i've never had a girl grab my wrist
like i was a child in trouble yeah
you know and put it down and she wanted
me to finger yeah now
of course i did but
[Laughter]
fantastic nothing or that a woman aged
24 years
a certain province in asia showers daily
showers daily
and there is no turf on the grass
but scorched the earth yeah but i just
remember
and the reason why i never took her to
to my room in my hotel is i looked at
her
this bitch's pupils were dilated she was
[ __ ] oh she was on one
on one dude i'm like this looks a little
uh
well thank you for that but i think i
will
i don't want to [ __ ] a girl that's like
on some [ __ ] like this is this is weird
yeah i i actually had that too i had a
situa well
i didn't finger the girl but then i was
dancing with her
and she was basically guiding my hand
like she wanted me to grab her tits
and then basically like you know feel
her up down there
i was like okay this is uh definitely
not the norm per se but
it's not so uncommon like it does happen
when people are just kind of like
into the like the mood and maybe into
you
and there they got you know alcohol in
them maybe even drugs in them and they
just
they get really into it you know i know
and [ __ ] happens but
finger in
because it was concerned this [ __ ] is
on one right now dude she's not gonna
remember who the [ __ ] i am yeah i mean
it sounded like she was really horny in
that moment maybe maybe she was
she was on e maybe she was oh she was
for sure on e
she was she was [ __ ] buzzed and i
don't know it's like she just needed
your hand as a tool like to
dog you know what the funniest part i
just remembered this [ __ ] was like
when literally when i was fingering her
right she's like feeling it like i'm
talking about like she's like her hand
is like running through my hair
that's what i was like yo this [ __ ] is
like she doesn't know where she's at
yeah she doesn't like there was a dude
that looked at me
went he gave the not bad fights
okay and i'm like hey i'm fingering a
girl in public right now this [ __ ] is
nuts
yeah you know yeah and you would think
hey i got anxiety issues right and i'm
like
am i literally [ __ ] somebody in
public yeah
yeah you know i'm like this is not me
the good thing is it's dark
you know and it's like loud dark enough
this guy made direct eye contact with me
is like bro you are
literally finger banging the [ __ ] out of
a girl right in front of my eyes
i'm like dude what the [ __ ] was this guy
doing was he just watching
i think he was just shocked he was like
no but like how do you like
you know because there like so much
movement and [ __ ] has happened like was
this dude
just kind of like standing around and
just watching he was dancing
but this girl though i'm talking about
she is like she's she was definitely on
e
or has to be i don't know i've never
done either but i'm assuming yeah
[ __ ] dilated pupils [ __ ]
you know what i mean like [ __ ] horny
as hell because i'm i'm behind her
because she was grinding it up on me
and then she grabs me and puts right i
remember she's just like
with this eye contact it's funny how
it's all coming back she goes she goes
don't pay attention to that she actually
noticed
because she's literally like so if i'm
behind her she's in front of me yeah
i'm fingering her and then she has her
hair and
hands up in my hair just rubbing my hair
like damn this [ __ ] look crazy right
now
and that's when you kind of snap out of
it it's like she's not even trying to be
discreet about the show
and i'm like i feel dirty right yeah i
mean she didn't give a [ __ ] so you know
she it seemed like she enjoyed herself
no no harm done there right she wanted
it
she used to listen to this podcast and
be like you are a filthy human being you
are a disgusting
human being hey man you always call me
at this i've never done anything like
that
how dare you let me tell you something
else it was not my idea
but you did it it was not my idea watch
when this [ __ ] turned on the lights the
lights turned out she was like oh my god
i thought you were way cuter i'm like
hey what happened happened oh
and you just trapped me okay i feel used
me just use me as a [ __ ] tool for my
dudes use me as a dildo
yeah exactly glorified [ __ ] vibrator
oh
yeah let me tell you some random [ __ ]
that also happened at that club
that they did that girl grabbed my dick
um
i was uh i was chilling and then i see
two dudes walking and like now mind you
the club wasn't popping
it was maybe like i don't know 50 60
capacity right so like the place the you
know there's crowds but then there's
definitely
like some empty spots too and then i
look
and and uh you know the reason why it
caught my attention because it's like
pretty much predominantly asian and it
was two black guys coming in
so i look i'm like wait why the [ __ ] do
i
do they look so familiar so i i look a
little closer and then they walk into
the vip section and they're the
literally the only ones in the vip
section just them too
and then they're just kind of chilling
and kind of scoping the place out
and i i look and i [ __ ] really you
you would not believe who the [ __ ] it
was [ __ ] gangstar
it was group really i was like what the
[ __ ]
is guru and primo doing at a 18 and over
asian nightclub where it's not even
popping they like asian girls
that that's what i figured but you know
me being a [ __ ] fan
i was like yo it's my [ __ ]
opportunity to make games
just came up to me i did it
so um i took the opportunity to uh
engage them
and you know how they uh at the reserve
tables they got those little placards
that says you know reserve
whatever i just grabbed one of those and
then i ripped one
and i went up to the yeah hey guru primo
i'm a huge fan you know been a fan of
your music for years can i can i get a
signature real quick
you know back then we didn't really have
the smartphones or whatever it's still
like signatures
so i i got their signature on the on the
back of a reserved placard that i just
ripped
and then um they were there i slapped
hands with them told them thanks and
then
they stuck around for maybe like 15 more
minutes they just bounced
i i think they came to to hunt but they
didn't like what they saw
what they said you still have that
signature somewhere i don't know dude i
i have no idea what i did with it i mean
it might be in like a storage box
somewhere
yeah yeah at my parents place but it's
crazy i don't remember yes it was so
[ __ ] random this fool was looking for
a little
asian honey so you know it was like a
great first experience
into like the club i was like yo man i
grinded with three girls at once one of
them grabbed my dick i met [ __ ]
gangstar yeah i was like this is a
fantastic night
now i'm like questioning like should i
leave that part up does mario listen to
this podcast
you can't cut that out that's a that's a
great [ __ ] story man
hey hey that was the pat this was yeah
that's what i'm saying it's like 10
years ago
it's not like you did this yes like 22
years old did this yesterday i'd be like
ooh dave yeah yeah
i don't know it's like 22 years old yeah
young young david yeah no i mean come on
man we all did it was a glorious
it was a day night i just couldn't i
just couldn't believe what was going on
yeah
yeah fantastic yeah that's that's
definitely a more
unique experience than the most uh most
people's club experiences
you know it's so sad too is like the
girl had to be on drugs for that to
happen
hey whatever the case is she was
enjoying yourself
you were enjoying yourself i'll tell you
what i can at that age yeah the other
guy was enjoying himself watching
he was shocked i remember his eyes he
was like okay
and i looked at him like okay i can't
believe this is going on either way this
is how they do it in boston yeah
you know i love that boston is great
fantastic well guys on that note not
that no that wraps up this episode of
the genius brain podcast
you can find edric ed too
uh write down in the comments what you
thought about you know the state of this
country and how this podcast ended with
[ __ ] grabbing
consensual irony consensual we'll see
you all next time